okie dokie this is silhouettes playing
silhouettes and that's a new opponent
some nums own action yeah check yeah
like Uncle Awards same ish you know I
recent match against grandmas a nuke
LaLoosh in bed I had a very nice
attacking win with the sameish but I
also lost one game pretty pretty
miserably so that opening and has again
proved that it is not good for drawing
but it's pretty good for fighting games
I came surprised that mr. silhouette CM
allowed them the pin as we have seen in
numerous of my games this is not a great
idea to allow the pin he is God night
BTW seven though that's a little bit
different than with the Knights stuck on
a five so let's close the position and
yeah I'm maintaining the pin I guess
even though we should be three has its
points but maintaining the pin is I
think okay so i will koji form
absolutely and wow
this is not an uncommon idea in general
but I don't believe in this that this
should be good in this particular
situation I can also bring the night
Jeff 5-under pretty favorable
circumstances just wonder let's start
with this after night f4 it's
interesting i think even night g3 is a
93 is an interesting idea I'm I'll go
for that without thinking too much 92 94
95 I mean yeah it's not good for white
something is entirely wrong with my my
perception of chess oh my what wrong is
I didn't see that but still still I
don't believe this for black it should
be pretty dangerous Wow okay um can also
go to e3 it's kind of debatable what's
better actually if i take here now this
is just great actually yes where is he
going there okay queen e 1 king age 7
come on that that is that stuff to
believe here where's he going if I play
kingi to King age seven Queen h1 and
rook g8 or something I can take these
six-hour like why not to f2 actually
yeah let's go to after I mean of course
I'm i probably could have played better
William and that's anyway
meet the rock on h1 that would put help
maybe still here and then look each one
unfortunately I'm not threatening a
discovery with the bishop at least I
don't see one ok night g3 now gets wins
the exchange back but is that helping I
have to check with a keen as well that's
not so great but anyway my main issue is
that i'm spending just to cry too much
time in check
I go screen g6 anyway what a shame that
that position was so good yum after like
move 15
damn this is just bad now ah i really i
really don't like it if they get get
away with stuff like that yeah neither
force going nothing to do slight resigns
that's a kind of sick really check yeah
chief chief I this terrible just a
terrible move I mean I don't have to
play this kind of spaces and I don't
have to play this in the shower boy I
can just play stuff like that I'm just
clearly better but I thought that this
is better I just didn't see that you can
take age for but this should also be
good for white and I mean that can
absolutely impossible ping that it can
never be good for black with the with
too passive pieces the Queen has no
squares so okay how does the comp kill
this King f2 so I'm right here and now
queen h 1y am a queen h1 just wins
basically no it's not when it doesn't
win but it's better for I'd g8 Bishop e7
okay so all right away it's not easy at
all you should see two for Bishop f4
activating this very strong this is the
engine line gap likes pretty much
falling apart here so this was the point
in I was seeing that here I would
challenge us to get the exchanger bag
but it doesn't really help me Quincy one
is so much better for white don't quite
understand why though sorry okay I'm
uncovering I'm covering the look of
course here and if he goes here what is
then Bishop d3 wins okay because I can
just take the others made on edge six
yeah so I should have just played this
normal move here I mean I did but I what
cat no I'm to earth and there's always a
bit tough to come back if you if you
really feel like you come spoiled a very
very nice position which definitely is
true so it's the same story at all over
again they get into that pin and and
then then moves like g fiber plate which
is just it's not playable really maybe i
should shouldn't try to punish those
kind of move so directly because normal
moves are completely okay yeah i mean
something like if we if you look at like
age for here and 93 i mean it's it's
it's an interesting try but i can if i
take i mean black is just in terrible
shape something like that
and then or move like this he just has a
wii king and the squares this is bad the
bishop is on b7 this is already more
than one porn+ of you if you ask
stockfish and yeah i don't need an
engine to see that so i shouldn't have
tried this fancy stuff i mean i can
actually add somebody didn't pay any
attention that age for was hanging I
mean I committed the same sin that my
opponents do all the time like playing
instantly in complicated positions I
should have yeah took a time timeout
them to learn to avoid that the engine
now and now that I have let it run
actually likes my move from it once you
go here and gives white a clear
advantage because this now is winning in
fact yeah well it's a bit of a
difference if the king is on f1 or d2
because now I much quicker get get stuff
over to the Kings side something like
that yeah it looks awful yeah magic
plate the opening too quickly okay
thanks for watching